knapp eine Million Menschen sind seit
Kriegsbeginn aus der Ukraine zu uns
geflüchtet und das könnten noch mehr
werden denn Russland zerstört weiter
Städte und Infrastruktur und daraus
anderen Staaten kommen wieder mehr
Menschen zu uns Städte und Gemeinden
schlagen Alarm weil sie nicht wissen wie
sie alle unterbringen sollen
bundesinnenministerin Phaser hat heute
Unterstützung zugesagt auf einem Treffen
mit Ländern und Kommunen zwischen
Hilfsbereitschaft und Überforderung
flüchtlingsgipfel in Berlin unser Thema
in der phoenix-runde
Phoenix Runde die Lage ist in der Tat
herausfordernd ernst und in vielen
vielen Fällen sind Kommunen an der
Grenze der Belastung schon jetzt
angekommen wir haben die ersten kleinen
Gemeinden die Turnhallen angemietet
haben wir haben uns ganz konkrete von
meiner Stadt zu sagen zwei Zeltstädte
repariert in Dresden ist eine Messehalle
gemietet das heißt die Situation
insgesamt der geflüchteten Menschen hat
eine Größenordnung erreicht die sehr
wohl vergleichbar ist mit den Jahren 15
und 16 wenn sie Ukraine geflüchtete
Menschen Lust weiter Asylsuchende
hinzuziehen dann zeigt das die
Herausforderung vor der wir stehen so
weit also Burkhard Jung er ist der
stellvertretende Präsident des Deutschen
Städtetages und Oberbürgermeister von
Leipzig einer Situation wie
2015/2016 sagte ja sprechen wir über die
steigenden Flüchtlingszahlen ich begrüße
Sie ganz herzlich hier aus Berlin und
darf in meine Gäste vorstellen vieles
pol bei uns seit 2017 im Bundestag für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen erst
migrationspolitische Sprecherin jetzt
Parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin und
herzlich willkommen Andrea Lindholz von
der
csu-stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
cdu/csu-fraktion für recht
innenvertriebene Aussiedler und deutsche
Minderheiten und zugeschaltet ist uns
Gerald Knaus er ist Migrationsforscher
und Gründungsdirektor der Denkfabrik
europäische stabilitätsinitiative und
herzlich willkommen Sabine Werth sie ist
Mitbegründerin und ehrenamtliche
Vorsitzende der Berliner Tafel herzlich
willkommen
Frau Lindholz jetzt haben wir es eben
gehört die Kommunen sind ziemlich am
Anschlag oder viele Kommunen und machen
sich Sorgen auch gerade jetzt mit Blick
auf den Winter es gibt ja nach wie vor
eine hohe Hilfsbereitschaft hier die
ukrainischen Flüchtlinge sie selber
haben der Innenministerin mal
Asylsystem vorgeworfen dass sie das
Asylsystem ins Chaos steuere jetzt heute
der flüchtlingsgipfel sind sie zufrieden
also erstmal nehmen wir natürlich der
Hilferuf der Kommunen schon seit einigen
Monaten war und der flüchtlingsgipfel
heute hat für mich noch nicht die
Ergebnisse gebracht die erbringen sollen
wir haben nach wie vor eine große
Hilfsbereitschaft was die ukrainischen
Flüchtlinge angeht
wir haben aber sehr stark steigende
Zahlen aus dem Bereich der
irregulären Migration aus anderen Teilen
und es gab eben heute keine Antworten
bei der Frage wie bringe ich die
Menschen unter die Kommunen 16 Jahr und
sagen wir haben keine
Unterbringungsmöglichkeiten mehr der
Bund hat aber doch zugesagt dass er
Immobilien bereitstellt und also man
muss auch mehr Plätze bereit man muss
aber sehen um welche Zahl es geht also
die Innenministerin hat heute gesagt es
sind 4000 Plätze sind 56 Unterkünfte zu
denen die sie schon bereitgestellt hat
die sind noch nicht vollständig belegt
dazu muss man aber sehen das sind
teilweise auch Grundstücke die unbebaut
sind also bei der Menge wir reden hier
von über einer Million Menschen sie
haben das gesagt bei der Menge ist es
natürlich heute ein Tropfen auf den
heißen werden was für die Kommunen noch
viel wichtiger ist ist die finanzielle
Unterstützung das ist ja seit so dass
sie seit Januar keine finanzielle
Unterstützung bekommen also beim Thema
Finanzen gab es heute keine Zusagen beim
Thema Unterbringung ist es zu wenig und
beim Thema wir mussten jetzt den letzten
Tagen sehen dass die Ukraine dass die
Menschen dort erneut von Putin schwer
angegriffen worden sind das heißt hier
hier bringt sie vielleicht auch noch mal
eine neue Lage im Winter wird sich noch
mal verschärfen auf auch darauf gab es
keine Antworten und auf die europäische
Komponente gab es auch keine Antworten
man kann hier vielleicht nicht alleine
in Vorwurf machen weil sie alleine ist
nicht für alles zuständig sie ist nicht
für das Thema Kita und sprachkita
zuständig um ein Beispiel zu nennen das
heißt hier ist auch der Kanzler
gefordert hier sind alle Ressorts
gefordert die von davon betroffen sind
und nicht nur die Innenministerin also
nicht genug Frau Bruder wenn man das
hört 4000 Plätze dauerhafte Plätze hat
die Innenministerin heute gesagt das
klingt wirklich wenig angesichts der
vielen Menschen die zu uns kommen kann
der Bund da nicht mehr leisten die muss
ich erst mal vehement widersprechen also
wir haben bisher drei ungefähr 300
Liegenschaften schon mietzinsfrei
überlassen mit 50.000 Plätzen Frau
Innenministerin Feser hat von 4.000
Immobilien gesprochen
4.000 Immobilien die freistehen bei der
Beamer ich würde sogar sagen 6.500 das
sind die beamerzahlen die sind im
Haushaltsausschuss so vorgetragen worden
und da müssen sie dann sehen dass das
natürlich
Liegenschaften sind wie zum Beispiel
ehemalige Kasernen wo dann sehr sehr
viele Plätze ertüchtigt werden können
also das ist also es war heute ehrlich
gesagt die die Rede von 56 Immobilien
die jetzt zur Verfügung gestellt werden
ich sag ja bei der Beamer
sind 4000 wohnungsähnliche Einrichtung
so heißt das bei der Beamer leer stehend
und ich sage das Potenzial ist sogar bei
6.500 darüber können wir uns jetzt
streiten das muss dann der Faktencheck
klären wir haben die Zahlen sozusagen
vom Haushaltsausschuss das sind die
Zahlen der Beamer das ist eine
Einrichtung von Herrn Lindner und da
würde ich nur sagen das ist ja schon
seit Mai zugesagt worden diese
mietzinsfrei zu überlassen und deswegen
das ist so ein bisschen meine Kritik
auch an uns selbst ich habe mit im
Landkreistag und mit dem Städtetag
gesprochen die selbst wenig angeboten
bekommen haben bisher
obwohl diese Immobilien leer stehen und
das sind nicht die Immobilien die
vielleicht Mängel aufweisen sondern das
sind tatsächlich die Immobilien die
sofort beziehbar sind das heißt es ist
Potenzial da das wollte ich nur damit
sagen und bei den Ländern ist es so da
gebe ich Frau Lindholz Recht die
Bundesländer sind ja dazu da
erstaufnahmekapazitäten zu schaffen und
deswegen das ist ja auch das was die
Kommunen angemahnt haben die
Bundesländer und dann nehme ich auch
unsere eigenen mitregierten Bundesländer
mit in die Pflicht müssen Kapazitäten
tatsächlich aufbauen angesichts der
höchsten Zahlen die wir seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg überhaupt an geflüchte haben
haben wir im Grunde genommen noch sehr
eine sehr interessante Situation nicht
wie 2015/16 sondern das jetzt erst die
Kommunen sagen so jetzt ist langsam Zeit
dass wir ein bisschen mehr Unterstützung
brauchen was gelernt hat aber ich würde
mir gerne Herrn Knaus dazu nehmen weil
wir reden dass wir zumindest am Anfang
alle einmal irgendwie zu Wort gekommen
sind wir sind auch gleich wieder dran
Herr Knaus man hört es ja die einen
Aufnahmeeinrichtungen sind an vielen
Orten natürlich voll und womit rechnen
sie denn jetzt für den für den Winter
also was muss ihrer Meinung nach
passieren damit eben ja die Kommunen und
Länder nicht noch weiter überfordert
werden
ja es ist ja sehr interessant als der
Krieg begonnen hat und er als in den
ersten vier Wochen dreieinhalb Millionen
ukrainische Flüchtlinge in die
Europäische Union kamen
da war ja schon absehbar dass das die
größte flüchtlingskrise werden wird seit
den 40er Jahren und damals waren die
Erwartungen und so wäre es auch gekommen
hätten die Ukraine nicht Kiew vor der
Eroberung bewahrt und die russischen
Truppen zurückgeschlagen
im März und im April die Erwartung war
damals schon dass bis zu 10 Millionen in
kürzester Zeit in die EU fliehen würden
wir wissen aber jetzt es sind bis jetzt
ungefähr sechseinhalb Millionen aus der
Ukraine nach Polen gekommen aber es sind
auch viereinhalb in die andere Richtung
zurückgegangen weil es der Ukraine
gelungen ist Städte zu halten Gebiet
zurückzuerobern und das hat zu einer
einem falschen
gefühlt ich weiß viele Minister ich habe
den engen Bundesländern haben im April
an eine Zahl von zwei Millionen für
Deutschland im Hinterkopf gedacht haben
schon darüber nachgedacht Messehallen
anzumieten und dann kamen die Menschen
nicht die Menschen sind in Polen
geblieben dort sind heute 1,4 Millionen
sie sind in der Tschechischen Republik
geblieben und nach Deutschland kamen sie
nur sehr langsam aber jetzt ist es so
wir haben die größte Zahl schon jetzt
mehr als 2015 darauf war niemand
vorbereitet das ist eine Ausnahme
historische Ausnahmesituation aber jetzt
muss dringend mit dem Szenario gerechnet
werden das Putins Krieg gegen die
Menschen gegen die Infrastruktur um mit
Terror eine
Massenvertreibung durchzusetzen um
Europa unter Druck zu setzen und zu
erpressen dass Europa sich darauf
vorbereitet und darauf sind wir nicht
vorbereitet vielleicht eine Zahl noch
Baden-Württemberg hat die höchsten
Flüchtlingszahlen eine Geschichte mit 11
Millionen Einwohnern
130.000 Ukrainerinnen dann 13.000 andere
Asylwerber das ist also eine sehr kleine
Zahl im Vergleich zu der Ukrainern
Tschechien hat
430.000 mehr als dreimal mehr als
Baden-Württemberg mit der gleichen
Bevölkerung wir sehen also die wirkliche
Krise derzeit findet statt in den
östlichen Nachbarn Deutschlands den
Baltikum Polen Tschechien die Slowakei
Deutschland spürt immer mehr weil jetzt
Leute eben auch hierher kommen das
Problem ist in Frankreich sind derzeit
weniger Flüchtlinge als in
Baden-Württemberg aus der Ukraine
nämlich nur 100.000 und darüber müsste
man genau darüber müssen wir auch reden
was auf EU-Ebene weil ich würde nur ganz
gern weil sie das angesprochen haben wir
haben eine Grafik da sieht man das ganz
gut auch die gucken wir uns mal kurz an
wie am Anfang die Statistik also die die
Zahlen hochgegangen sind nämlich der
allgemeine Zuzug und der ist blaue ist
die ist ja Zuzug aus der Ukraine und wir
dann halt eben danach wieder runter
gegangen ist das war halt eben dieser
Pik wo man dann auch mehr gerechnet hat
und ist dann aber wieder zurückgegangen
Frau Werth sie versorgen ja oder die
Berliner Tafel versorgt auch immer mehr
Menschen aus der Ukraine die geflüchtet
sind
wie merken Sie das ist mehr Menschen
gibt die hierher kommen und die ja Hilfe
brauchen was hat sich da entwickelt in
den letzten Monaten wir merken das
schlicht und ergreifend in dem die
Menschen vor uns stehen die sind wie vom
Himmel gefallen plötzlich vor unserer
Zentrale gewesen wo wir nie Lebensmittel
ausgeben und es hat sich aber in
Windeseile offensichtlich rund
rumgesprochen da ist die Berliner Tafel
die Berliner Tafel verteilt Lebensmittel
da geht mal hin das heißt wir haben
innerhalb kürzester Zeit
ein Informationszettel auf Ukrainisch
übersetzen lassen dann haben wir
mitgekriegt ganz viele von denen
sprechen ja gar nicht Ukrainisch sondern
russisch also haben das ganze noch mal
auf Russisch gemacht damit wir den
Menschen
verständ machen können dass wir zum
einen eben keine Versorgungsstelle
sondern eine Unterstützung sind für die
Versorgung ist die Politik zuständig wir
können nur unterstützen und haben den
bei der Gelegenheit eben auch zum einen
die Art wie wir arbeiten versucht zu
erklären und die nächste Ausgabestelle
die für Sie in Betracht kamen genannt
inzwischen ist es so wir hatten vor dem
Krieg und vor der Inflation das müssen
wir an der Stelle einfach beides denken
etwa 40.000 Menschen die im Monat zu
unseren 47 Ausgabestellen gekommen sind
inzwischen sind es 76.000 das heißt das
ist eine Steigerung umfasst unter Druck
nicht nur von Seiten aus der Flüchtlinge
sondern auch von Menschen die halt eben
Probleme haben
alle gleichzeitig jetzt gerade bei uns
vor der Tür und das ist natürlich
richtig massiv genau da müssen wir auch
darüber sprechen was das wie der
gesellschaftliche Druck da ist Frau
Lindholz aber ich mag sie waren schon
ganz nervös sie wollten gerne
wichtiges gesagt man ist natürlich im
Frühjahr tatsächlich von steigenderen
zahlen Übergang und das ist ja deshalb
umso unverständlicher dass wir auf zwei
Ebenen seitdem eigentlich nicht richtig
reagiert haben einmal innerhalb
Deutschlands weil es tatsächlich
absehbar war dass die Zahlen noch
steigen können wir sehen das jetzt dass
wir gerade in Deutschland auch im
Bereich irreguläre Migration eigentlich
auch keine Schritte unternommen haben
dass wir die Kommunen seit Anfang des
Jahres mit ihren mit dem Thema im Regen
stehen lassen die haben das jetzt nicht
zum ersten Mal moniert sondern seit
Monaten und dass wir die europäische
Ebene nicht ausreichend betrachten die
massenzustromsrichtlinien die man damals
zu Recht gezogen hat weil es in der
Situation eine gute Lösung war sie zwei
Dinge voraus sie sieht voraus dass man
sich auf einen Verteilungsschlüssel
verständigt und sie sieht voraus dass
man ein gemeinsames System der
Registrierung schafft an diesem
gemeinsamen System der Registrierung
wird immer noch gearbeitet die
ungleichmäßige Verteilung innerhalb
Europas hat der Knaus gerade angerissen
und es ist für die Menschen aus der
Ukraine die auch zu uns kommen natürlich
auch wichtig dass wir sie auch von ihrem
Schutzbedarf her bestmöglichst das kann
jetzt nicht bedeuten dass die Lösung wir
bauen jetzt wieder
Hallen auf wir bringen Menschen wieder
in Turnhallen unter das ist keine Lösung
das heißt ich brauche auch eine
europäische Verständigung wenn es jetzt
in der Ukraine wieder schwieriger wird
und andere Zahlen auf uns zukommen dass
das was
dieser europäischen Lösung haben wir ja
schon seit 2015 Unterschied ist ein
Unterschied der Unterschied ist die
ukrainischen Flüchtlinge sind
Kriegsflüchtlinge aus der Nachbarschaft
die auch wieder in absehbarer Zeit wenn
der Krieg vorbei ist in ihrer Heimat
zurück wollen wir haben die
massenzustromsrichtlinien die gezogen
weil wir gesagt haben da kommt innerhalb
einer kürzester Zeit aufgrund dieses
Krieges in unserer Nachbarschaft eine
große Mensch an Menschen vor allen
Dingen Frauen und Kinder in die
europäischen Nachbarländer und das muss
entsprechend auch
aufgenommen werden und deswegen sieht
diese massenzustromsrichtlinie das auch
vor was ich kritisiere ist dass man
beide Felder die Handlung in Deutschland
und in Europa monatelang nicht weiter
betrieben hat und sich jetzt wundert
dass unsere Kommunen sie sind im
Dezember nicht mehr aufnahmefähig und
sich ein letzter Satz noch Anfang
September haben sich 12 Bundesländer aus
dem easy-verteilung mal ein ausgeklinkt
das sind Fakten keiner kommen zu 70
Prozent privat unter und das ist der
große Unterschied zu 2015 zwei 16 das
war auch kein Zufall dass die Richtlinie
erstmalig nach 20 Jahren aktiviert wurde
sondern unsere Innenministerin hat sich
sehr stark dafür engagiert zum einen
gleichzeitig gab es sozusagen ein
visa-abkommen mit der Ukraine so dass
die geflüchteten
ukrainischen geflüchteten so oder so
sich frei bewegen konnten aufgrund
dieses wieseabkommens und diese zwei
Dinge haben dazu geführt dass zum Glück
diese Richtlinie aktiviert wurde die man
auch schon
2015 zwei 16 hätte aktivieren können
warum das war der große Vorteil deswegen
haben wir keine Überlastung der Systeme
gehabt die Menschen hatten sofort einen
Schutzstatus das heißt man sagt da
kommen Menschen offensichtliches
Kriegsgebiet sie müssen kein
Asylverfahren durchlaufen wir
deklarieren sofort sie sind
Kriegsflüchtlinge das hilft das hat man
bei Syrien nicht getan und der große
Unterschied ist Ukrainer innen müssen
nicht in Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung alle
anderen werden Wohnsitz verpflichtet in
Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung zu wohnen mein
Präsident allererstaufnahmeeinrichtung
also
Flüchtlingsunterkünfte in Niedersachsen
sagt wir haben ein großes Potenzial von
Betten die jetzt belegt werden weil da
geflüchtete gezwungen werden sich
Wohnsitz zu verpflichten warum macht man
es nicht wie bei den Ukrainern warum
können die nicht zu ihren
Familienangehörigen meine Kollegin heute
aus Bayern schöne Grüße nach Bayern hat
gesagt wir haben jetzt einen Antrag
gemacht weil wir haben bestimmt 30
Prozent Büßerin demirée 30 Prozent von
Menschen die verpflichtet werden in
einer Einrichtung zu wohnen und obwohl
sie Familie haben okay das wären das
sind die Lehren die man aus der Ukraine
jetzt ziehen muss das würde sofort nicht
nur Länder entlassen sondern auch die
Kommunen darüber müssten wir mal
irreguläre Migration das sind
keine irregulären geflüchteten machen
Sie bitte zwei Klassen keine zwei
Klassengesellschaft zwischen
geflüchteten haben gesagt wir wollen die
afghanischen geflüchteten nicht im Stich
lassen ich würde ganz gerne einmal die
übersichtliche Drittländer die kommen
wir sichere Länder zu uns nach
Deutschland das ist natürlich eine
irreguläre Migration nein Deutschland
hier ein Asylantrag stellt darf nach der
Genfer Flüchtlingskonvention und es ist
kein Dublin geflüchteter hier Frau Pohl
hat der erst hier einen Asylantrag
stellt der kommt aber der kommt aber
über sichere Drittländer zu uns und das
ist ja genau der Punkt dass wir sehen
dass auch also keiner hier das habe ich
nicht gesagt ich habe nur gesagt wir
sehen dass die anderen europäischen
Länder ja dafür sorgen dass bei uns
wieder die Flüchtlinge im Rahmen des
unter anderem der sekundär-migration
zunehmen wir sehen dass Serbien 100
Staaten Visa frei Visafreiheit
eingeräumt hat unter anderem Afghan
Syrien und dem Irak und wir brauchen
eine andere ja wir brauchen eine andere
Verteilung innerhalb Europas nein das
ist nicht falsch wird ganz gerne hat
eben 100 Ländern
die bundesinnenministerin hat dazu heute
auch was gesagt eben zu der Flugbewegung
die nicht nur aus der Ukraine kommt
sondern auch über die Balkanroute würde
gerade ganz gerne diesen kleinen dieses
kleine Zitat eben mal hören
neben der großen Flucht
Bewegung derzeit auch über das
Balkanroute wieder deutlich mehr
Menschen nach Europa und das macht mir
Sorge
die asylantragszahlen sind in den
letzten Monaten gestiegen ebenso wie die
Zahlen unerlaubter einreisen nicht nur
in Deutschland sondern insgesamt in den
EU-Außengrenzen steigt der Druck derzeit
an deshalb müssen wir auch klar für eine
Begrenzung Sorgen ich habe dazu ein
Bündel an Maßnahmen ergriffen und heute
die Ländern Kommunen über weitere
Schritte informiert für eine Begrenzung
sorgen sagte Innenministerin Frau Werth
aus ihrer Alltagsarbeit sagen sie auch
wir sind an einem Punkt wo wir das nicht
mehr schaffen Deutschland
ich sehe das nicht so weil ich glaube
dass wir auch 15 16 17 bewiesen haben
dass wir sehr viel schaffen und wir
schaffen auch das was wir Tafeln halt
merken Land auf Land ab wir haben extrem
zu wenig Lebensmittel wir sind ganz
bewusst ich sagte es bereits
unterstützend tätig aber diese
Unterstützung fällt uns in bei allen
Tafeln immer schwerer weil wir einfach
wirklich immer weniger Lebensmittel
bekommen zum Teil schicken die Firmen
ihre Überschüsse direkt in die Ukraine
zum Teil machen sie auch ganz bewusst
abendliche Abverkäufe das ist auf der
einen Seite für uns natürlich schön weil
wir in den gesamten Chor der
Lebensmittel rettenden Organisationen
gehören und unter dem Gesichtspunkt
finden wir das ganz toll das auf die Art
und Weise dass eben nicht auf dem Müll
oder in den Containern landet aber auf
der anderen Seite sind das alles
Lebensmittel die wir eigentlich am
nächsten Morgen abholen würden und
merken sie damit den Bedürftigen nicht
mehr zu gut und merken sie da sozusagen
eine Konkurrenz unter dem Bedürftigen
wenn dann viele sagen die an wenn manche
Menschen merken jetzt kommen immer mehr
Flüchtlinge und dafür deshalb reicht das
nicht mehr für alle
wir versuchen eben an dieser Stelle auch
immer wieder auf die Solidarität zu
pochen und an die Leute zu appellieren
die Stimmung ist noch gut also wir haben
noch nicht das Problem dass sie
übereinander herfallen und da in großen
sozialen Neid verfallen sie merken nur
insgesamt dass sie weniger bekommen als
sie jemals von uns vorher hatten und das
macht sich bemerkbar aber es ist nicht
auf der Ebene und nur weil die
Flüchtlinge jetzt da sind bekommen wir
so wenig sondern sie haben wirklich alle
kapiert es liegt am Markt dass wir
gerade so wenig haben okay aber Frau
Burda wenn die Innenministerin sagt wir
müssen für eine Begrenzung Sorgen wie
interpretieren sie das naja das hat die
Innenministerin ja auch gesagt dass es
um Grenzkontrollen geht und da würden
wir auch glaube ich wir haben sie morgen
im Innenausschuss erstmal ein Dissens
anmelden ich möchte aber vielleicht
vorweg sagen mich hat tatsächlich
irritiert seit längerem dass hier von
Besorgnis gesprochen wird das führt ja
auch so ein bisschen Ängste weil wir
eigentlich bei den Fluchtbewegungen über
Griechenland und dann die die Länder
Serbien
Bosnien-Herzegowina also die das
westlichen Balkans immer steigende
Zahlen haben im August September das ist
relativ normal und die Zahlen werden
verglichen mit dem Vorjahr das ist noch
das covet-jahr gewesen das heißt wir
haben hohe Zahlen unbestritten das will
ich auch nicht verharmlosen aber es ist
keine Zahl die man jetzt vergleichen
muss mit zwei 15 zwei 16 wir haben jetzt
sogar im September stand heute habe ich
mir noch mal von IOM geholt rückläufige
Zahlen was Serbien betrifft was
Griechenland betrifft sind wochenzahlen
die sozusagen bei uns eintreffen in der
Woche und von daher würde ich erstmal
sagen nichts unbenommen müssen wir
erstaufnahmekapazitäten bei den Ländern
erhöhen weil die Länder haben
Kapazitäten abgebaut trotz hoher zahlen
die Kommunen müssen wir unterstützen
aber Frau Lindholz die Kommunen haben
von uns zwei Milliarden Euro bekommen
mit den kommendes Geld das müssen die
Länder weitergeben sie wissen der Bund
gibt an die Länder in den Ländern nicht
angekommen es ist adressiert an die
Kommunen die zwei Milliarden und die
Einigung das hat die Ministerin ja auch
gesagt für eine Fortsetzung der
Unterstützung der Kosten kommt jetzt
zeitnah im November das wurde auch von
allen begrüßt und städtetagspräsident
und auch Herr Jung haben gesagt wir sind
auf einem guten Weg wenn die Gelder
jetzt fließen wenn die Kapazitäten
aufgebaut werden und auch sich bedankt
für die Überlassung der bundesimmobilien
Liegenschaften sind wir auf jeden Fall
gut also das heißt sie sind sie sagen
man braucht keine Begrenzung würde ich
gerne Herrn Knaus frankenhaus wie sehen
sie es inwieweit sind die Zahlen steigen
die inwieweit muss man ja also oder wie
wie würden Sie die Fluchtbewegung
beobachten Frau Polat gesagt das ist
immer so September Oktober das ist
ansteigt also ist das eine Beobachtung
die sie teilen
wir haben eine wirklich paradoxe
Situation das nämlich nach Deutschland
und Österreich relativ im Vergleich zu
den letzten drei Jahren relativ viele
Asylanträge gestellt werden es sind aber
immer noch weniger als 2018 und es ist
kein Vergleich mit 2015/16 also das ist
vollkommen klar aber es stimmt in
Österreich und Deutschland sind viele
Asylanträge aber wir haben nicht viele
Menschen die über das Mittelmeer
irregulär die EU erreichen die Zahlen
für Griechenland in diesem Jahr die
irregulären Griechenland auf der Land
und das Seegrenze ankommen liegen bei
unter 15.000 bis jetzt
wir haben im ganzen letzten Jahr nur
15.000
Afghanen und Syrer gehabt 2021 die
irregulären die EU gekommen sind jetzt
fragt man sich woher kommen die 10.000
Syrer und Afghanen die in Deutschland
einen Asylantrag stellen die aber nicht
in den letzten eineinhalb Jahren in die
EU gekommen sind und die Antwort ist
klar die sind zum Großteil schon
jahrelang in der EU gewesen und zwar in
den Ländern Südosteuropas wir haben eine
und im österreichischen Innenministerium
internen Dokumenten habe ich den Begriff
gesehen die Entleerung der Balkanroute
wir haben derzeit einen Prozess das
viele die wir vor zwei Jahren im
Fernsehen gesehen haben auf den
griechischen Inseln auf dem griechischen
Festland in Lagen in Bosnien diese Lager
diese flüchtlingsaufnahmezentren in
Bosnien sind heute Lehrer als vor einem
Jahr auf den griechischen Inseln sind
nur noch 3.500 Menschen auf dem
griechischen Festland sind nur noch
geschätzt um die 30.000 das heißt was
wir hier erleben und
er hat eine große Konsequenz für die
Erwartungen
also ich glaube in den nächsten Monaten
wird diese Zahl der nicht Ukrainer die
einen Antrag stellen die wird im Winter
runtergehen und ich glaube die wird im
nächsten Jahr niedrig bleiben okay die
große Krise die wir haben sind die
Ukrainerinnen okay genau ich Begründer
warum ich ich habe da ein bisschen meine
Zweifel daran Herr Knaus dass das
wirklich der corona-effekt ist also zum
ersten haben wir an allen an der
tschechischen Grenze steigende Zahlen
Bundespolizei ich will es einfach mal
feststellen die Bundespolizei hat uns
klar mitgeteilt an den an der
tschechischen Grenze steigende Zahlen
wir sind bei 900 Tschechen hat ja auch
die Grenzkontrollen eingeräumt wir haben
an der österreichischen
deutsch-österreichischen Grenze
steigende Zahlen an der Schweizer Grenze
steigende Zahlen und wir haben die
Ankündigung Erdogans dass er sich er hat
vier Millionen syrische Flüchtlinge bei
sich er steht innenpolitisch extrem
unter Druck er hat nächstes Jahr Wahlen
und er hat angekündigt er will eine
Million frische Flüchtlinge abschieben
dann können wir uns gut überlegen wohin
er diese syrischen Flüchtlinge
abschieben will und ich glaube deshalb
nicht daran dass die Zahlen signifikant
zurückgehen es wäre schön wenn die
Zahlen zurückgehen nur ich glaube dass
wir dafür Maßnahmen brauchen und dass
wir da auch Zeichen brauchen die
Ministerin heute hat selber gesagt der
Druck auf die Außengrenzen steigt sie
hat selber gesagt der schleuserwesen
steigt wie das kann man in der PK von
ihr alles einfach auch nachhören und
wenn ich das höre dann steht das im
Widerspruch dazu dass sie sagen sie
glauben dass die Zahlen quasi nächstes
Jahr
wie erklären sie sich denn das dass es
mehr Asylanträge in Deutschland gibt
dass die Menschen halt eben wie ein
Klaus eben gesagt aus Südosteuropa dann
doch nach Deutschland also ich glaube
das ist da das ist das ist einfach
multikausal ist dass sie was die
Menschen tatsächlich ein Teil wird sich
in Anrainer starten also zu Deutschland
angrenzen Staaten aufgehalten haben aber
war im Prinzip auch schon sicheren
Drittstaaten ein Teil hat sich aus der
Türkei auf den Weg gemacht also ein Teil
wäre es Serbien ich habe es vorhin
gesagt hat die die Freiheit eingeführt
wir sehen aus deshalb auch aus diesem
Bereich heraus und steigenden Druck auch
nach Deutschland und das ist dieses Mal
multicausal ist wir haben nicht eine
Route wir haben nicht eine Bewegung aber
wir haben einen entscheidenden
Unterschied zu 2015 nicht was die Zahlen
angeht sondern was die unterschiedlichen
Bereiche angeht wir haben jetzt die
Situation des Krieges in der Ukraine das
sind eine Million Menschen und wir haben
das Thema irreguläre Migration und auch
die Türkei Weißrussland wo die Menschen
auch auch über Polen zu uns kommen und
deswegen müssen wir das auch getrennt
betrachten aber ich glaube nicht dass
man sagen kann dass die Zahlen generell
dauerhaft zurückgehen werden wenn wir
dem nicht auch was entgegen die Frage
ist ja warum Deutschland dann immer so
attraktiv ist Frau Pohler da sagen halt
eben also zum Beispiel CDU-Chefin mehrz
sagt es gibt die
pull-faktoren man schafft falsche
Anreize weil unsere Sozialleistungen so
hoch sind was sagen sie denn dem naja
also ich glaube
da müssen wir wirklich aufpassen und das
ist ja ziemlich schnell auch entlarvt
worden dass er da einer telegram
Nachricht aufgesessen ist der Kringel
hat sich bei ihm bedankt für diese
Desinformationskampagnen die ja von
Putin unter anderem
und seinen Verstärkern hier auch Europa
erreichen was meinen Sie jetzt genau
naja es wurde er hat ja von
sozialtourismus gesprochen ich wollte
dieses Wort eigentlich nicht wiederholen
und das dafür auch Entschuldigung und da
hat er sich für entschuldigt hat dann
zwei Tage nachgelegt und wir hören immer
noch von CDU und CSU
sozialleistungsmissbrauch und
pullfaktoren obwohl im Innenausschuss
eine Unterrichtung auch vom Bundes von
der Bundesregierung eingefordert wurde
die genau das widerlegt es gibt
überhaupt keine Anzeichen dafür dass
Menschen keine Erkenntnisse geflüchte
geflüchtete kommen um hier
Sozialleistungen zu bekommen wegen des
Bürgergeldes weil wir haben ja den
rechtskreiswechsel vollzogen wo ich
gehofft habe dass dann nicht
ukrainer:innen ihre Tafeln erreichen
sondern zumindest mit der Absicherung
hier nicht zur Tafel müssen
im Gegenteil die Kommunen haben gesagt
vor allem das Städtetag hat gesagt das
war sehr erfolgreich der
rechtskreiswechsel weil er vor allem die
Kommunen entlastet hat von den
Sozialhilfeleistungen ich finde wir
müssen sehr aufpassen wenn wir solche
narrative bedienen die vor allem von den
Rechten bedient werden oder wenn es
Desinformationskampagnen sind weil
Ukrainer innen vor einem Jahr Frauen und
Kinder kommen hierher um Schutz zu
suchen und nicht weil sie hier die
Sozialleistung in Anspruch nehmen wollen
und im Gegenteil Frau Lindholz ich bin
mir nicht sicher wir müssen damit
rechnen dass der Krieg sehr sehr lange
dauert zumindest so planen wir unsere
Politik auch vor und von daher kann man
auch dort sich aus alten
Fluchtbewegungen gucken wie viele
Menschen wieder zurückgehen werden und
wie viele Menschen auch bleiben werden
bei den Ukrainerinnen kann man es nicht
so genau sagen weil ihre Männer ja auch
kämpfen und dort geblieben sind aber
sobald Kinder in die Schule gehen hier
in den Kinder eingehen und die Frauen ja
auch arbeiten dürfen kann das auch sein
dass sie die Männer dann hierher holen
genau
für die Kinder entscheiden die hier eben
Freunde gefunden haben Sie denn dazu
dass es das gesagt wird hier sind die
Sozialleistungen so gut in Deutschland
das ist ein Anreiz das halt eben dann
Tafel ja nicht dass Menschen dann
hierher kommen die Sozialleistungen sind
eindeutig nicht so gut und natürlich
haben wir auch in den letzten Jahren
immer wieder erlebt dass gerade Menschen
aus Rumänien Bulgarien und so hierher
kam Hartz IV bezogen haben dann aber
auch wieder gegangen sind für die war
das eine Summe die in keinem Verhältnis
zu dem stand was sie in ihrem eigenen
Land hätten verdienen können also von
daher ist auch das nachvollziehbar dass
das passiert ist aber die Menschen die
hier leben und die vor allem im
Augenblick in dieser Zeit der extremen
Inflation hier leben und hier existieren
wollen die haben große Schwierigkeiten
und wir haben Situationen ich habe von
einer alleinerziehenden gehört die den
Tag über wenig ist damit ihre Kinder
noch was zu essen haben das sind
Zustände da kann ich nicht behaupten
dass die Sozialleistungen in unserem
Land so auskömmlich sind dass die
Menschen überhaupt keine Probleme mehr
haben und auch das Bürgergeld mit den 50
€ mehr ist für meine Begriffe netter
Versuch aber schlecht gemacht Herr Knaus
trotzdem sie haben ja gesagt eben dass
das für viele dann Deutschland doch
attraktiv ist was welche
Schlussfolgerung ziehen sie und wo sagen
sie wenn man versucht es auf
europäischer Ebene zu
lösen zu ändern wo könnte man da
ansetzen denn das hat ja schon 2015/2016
nicht wirklich funktioniert
ja also vielleicht zwei Worte kann ich
noch eine Sache sagen zu dieser auch von
der Innenministerin angekündigten Idee
von Grenzkontrollen um irreguläre
Migration nach Deutschland zu reduzieren
da wette ich mein Haus das wird keine
einzige Person abhalten denn österreich
hat bei vielen Jahren Innenminister der
ÖVP der Tradition von Sebastian Kurz die
waren immer an der Macht und Österreich
hat durch seine Grenzkontrollen
niemanden abgehalten wir hatten in der
ersten Hälfte dieses Jahres mehr
Asylanträge in Österreich als in jedem
Jahr seit 2015 die wirklich der
wirkliche Grund liegt natürlich darin
dass viele Staaten südlich von
Österreich zwischen ja mittlerweile
zwischen der türkischen Grenze und und
Österreich und Deutschland eine sehr
zynische Politik machen die griechische
Regierung hat seit zwei Jahren die
Bedingungen für
Asylsuchende und anerkannte Flüchtlinge
in Griechenland so drastisch verschärft
dass Menschen in großer Zahl dazu
gedrängt wurden Richtung Norden zu gehen
und das dann deutsche Gerichte es
verbieten selbst anerkannte Flüchtlinge
zurückzuschicken also wir haben eine
asylwüste zwischen Athen und Wien wo
niemanden Asylantrag stellt nicht in
Ungarn nicht in Slowenien nicht in
Kroatien und dann kommen natürlich die
Leute nach Deutschland Österreich aber
vielleicht ein ein Wort zu Ihrer Frage
wie wir wie wir jetzt Weiterkommen
in Europa wir haben bei den
Ukrainerinnen eine einzige oder Ukraine
eine einzigartige Situation die dürfen
überall hin 50.000 sind in Flugzeuge
gestiegen nach Irland geflogen und
werden dort aufgenommen was wir brauchen
und es gab Ansätze dazu auch der
Außenministerin Annalena baerbock im
April zu sagen organisieren wir doch
eine Verteilung eine Koalition eine
solidaritätsmechanismus das ist aber
dann wieder eingeschlafen da ist fast
nichts passiert weil man dann dachte die
gehen eh bald wieder zurück jetzt wissen
wir wir brauchen Mechanismen und da
brauchen wir keine einig auf staatlicher
Ebene weil Ukrainer wenn ich erfahre es
gibt eine eine aufnahmegemeinde eine
Region Valencia Barcelona
Bordeaux Dublin die können hinfahren da
muss keine Regierung zustimmen aber man
muss die Information organisieren das
sehen wir schon in Deutschland und die
Tatsache dass Spanien Italien und
Frankreich zusammen weniger Ukraine
aufgenommen haben als Tschechien da ist
ein Zeichen dass es der letzte
fähransatz an die Grenzen stößt also was
ich vorschlagen würde ist wirklich diese
Idee ich weiß nicht wer von wem sie kam
CDU oder FDP oder auch die Regierung
aber einen europäischen Gipfel zu machen
aber den gut vorzubereiten okay
zu reden das wird nicht funktionieren
aber Anreise schaffen um dahin zu gehen
die die die Religionsgemeinschaften
einbinden nicht weinen Rom sprach mit
der katholischen Kirche wenn da Sante
gigi und andere line Organisationen
mobilisieren gibt es Familien in Italien
die Leute aufnehmen und dann musste
Informationen nach dorthin getragen
werden wo die Leute ankommen okay wir
könnten man sehr sehr viel mehr machen
okay genau ich würde gerne Frau lindert
sondern mal so hören also wäre das was
wo man sagt wer auf diese Art schafft
man es eben dass Menschen anders
verteilt werden wäre das wichtig
ich würde ganz gerne kurz auf Herrn März
eingehen ich will auf die Ukrainerinnen
und Ukraine eingehen um wirklich noch
mal klar zu sagen dass auch dort Frauen
nach mal zurück nach Hause fahren um
ihre Männer zu sehen das können wir
nachvollziehen ich will das mit aller
Deutlichkeit sagen wenn wir uns die
Frage stellen können die Leiste
Sozialleistungen bei uns ein Anreiz sein
dann spreche ich da auch von anderen
Ländern da spreche ich auch den Bereich
der irregulären Migration an weil da ist
es so wir haben eine hervorragendes
Gesundheitssystem und wir haben ein
gutes
sozialleistungssystem das ist ein
pull-faktor nach Deutschland das wissen
wir was brauchen wir aber wir brauchen
zwei Dinge wir bräuchten auch hier
endlich eine europäische Einigung was
das Thema
asylbewerberleistungen angeht Leistungen
generell das ist so unterschiedlich
innerhalb Europas dass es völlig klar
ist wenn ich die Chance habe mir das
Land auszusuchen wo ich für mich da am
besten auch die Leistungen erhaltet das
ist kein Vorwurf das ist ein Fakt und
deswegen brauchen wir da auch endlich
eine europäische Lösung die wir die
Leistungen mindern zu es geht nicht nur
mindern es geht da um eine Verständigung
um eine Einigung wäre es auch für wen
zuständig da gab es ja schon in der
Vergangenheit Lösungen auch da hat sich
Europa bis jetzt nicht auf dem
gemeinsames System geeinigt und das ist
ein Fehler alle anderen europäischen
Länder für ein Restriktionen ein fahren
ihre Flüchtlingspolitik in immer härtere
Regime auch Schweden auch Dänemark und
das müssen wir einfach sehen und das
führt für uns einfach zu Problemen und
was Herr Knaus sagt ist natürlich ein
wichtiger Punkt genau ich habe noch eine
Rückfrage wenn ich diese wenn ich die
massenzustromsrichtlinie ziehe was
nachvollziehbar und verständlich war im
der Ukraine Situation dann bedingt die
aber doch auch dass die Länder sich dann
verständigen wie entsprechend man auch
sie nennen es Anreize ich nenne es auch
Verteilung wie man das Organisieren kann
und daran fehlt es Putin bombardiert
jetzt wieder die Zivilbevölkerung in der
Ukraine und wir wollen diese Menschen
schützen dazu braucht es in Europa
Lösungen
Regierungschefs auch zusammenschließen
da wäre der Frau Polle damit wären sie
doch dann auch wenn sie so oft anderer
Meinung sind als Frau Lindas aber das
wäre doch was wo sie sagen das wäre ein
richtiger Ansatz oder verstehst die
Position der Union die Union will ja am
Hotspot System festhalten also das
Parken von geflüchteten irgendwo an den
EU-Außengrenzen aber
wir reden gerade von der
massenzustromsrichtlinie
europäischen Gipfel gar keine
Verbesserung des Systems weil bei der
von Herrn Knaus angesprochenem
solidaritätsmechanismus der ja sozusagen
stattfindet ist das Problem nach wie vor
Ukrainer in dürfen sich frei bewegen
jetzt sagt Herr Knaus soll mit Anreizen
gearbeitet werden wir hatten ja gesagt
in organisieren können woanders hin zum
Beispiel wir organisieren Flieger nach
Frankreich meinetwegen dann auch mit
Kirchengemeinden etc aber die meisten
Ukrainer in das sehen wir auch an den
wie die Unterbringung ist sind privat
untergekommen bei Freunden Familien
Verwandten oder eben so wie in meiner
Kommune wir haben viele Unternehmen die
sozusagen
dependosen in der Ukraine haben darf man
nicht unterschätzen wir haben einen
regenhandel zwischen Deutschland und der
Ukraine wo dann Betriebe gesagt haben
wir kümmern uns um eure Frauen also wir
haben ganz viele Frauen von
Beschäftigten die in diesen Firmen in
der Ukraine arbeiten so und da kann man
noch so viel nach Frankreich oder nach
Spanien schicken warum soll jemand nach
Spanien wenn die Tante oder ein enger
Freund in Buxtehude bei uns in
Niedersachsen trotzdem haben wir ja ein
Problem dass es für die Kommunen eng
wird und da ist ja die Frage wie man wie
man damit umgeht also sind ja nicht alle
die privatanfänger sind auch viele
privat untergekommen und weil man dachte
nach ein paar Monaten finden die dann
eine eigene Wohnung oder ziehen wieder
aus also die Kommunen berichten ist doch
auch Frau Pohler die Kommunen berichten
dass jetzt Menschen aus der Ukraine eine
Wohnung suchen weil jetzt genau eintritt
was wie sie vorhin gesagt haben es ist
kein schnelles Ende des Krieges zu sehen
und wir müssen die uns sollen wollen die
doch auch vernünftig unterbringen und
die Kommunen sagen dass sie da auch an
ihre Grenzen stoßen bloß wir können
Menschen nicht irgendwo hinschicken wo
sie dann wiederkommen
Lösungen die sozusagen für die Kommunen
auf der einen Seite eine Planbarkeit
bedeuten das ist bei Fluchtbewegung
immer etwas schwierig man kann es über
Aufnahmeprogramme ein bisschen steuern
und wir müssen Kommunen unterstützen und
das war die Forderung von den Kommunen
bitte für die übrigen geflüchteten
entweder mehr erstaufnahmekapazitäten
bei den Ländern
ja es geht aber darum die Kommunen sagen
nicht sie haben ein Problem mit
ukrainer:innen nein die haben eigentlich
fünf Minuten haben
bei den übrigen geflüchteten und das
sprechen wir von Afghanen von Syrern von
türkischen geflüchteten eine Zahl die
tatsächlich auch steigt Iran das sind
keine Menschen die Sozialleistungen hier
bei uns erschleichen sondern aus kriegs-
und Krisengebieten kommen und die
türkischen geflüchteten kommen auch
nicht weil sie hier Sozialleistungen
haben wollen Frau Lindholz weil sie das
immer wiederholen alle Haupt
Herkunftsländer kommen weil es Krieg und
Krisen Wiederholungen
was fragen genauso wollten sie da noch
was zu sagen hatte ich das richtig
gesehen ist ja für zwei Beispiele es gab
ja dieses Projekt diesen Vorschlag von
der Außenministerin für eine Luftbrücke
aus Moldau da haben sich tatsächlich
Länder gemeldet Ukraine aufzunehmen und
dann hat sich niemand gemeldet und dann
bin ich nach Moldau Gefahren sprach dort
mit dem Außenminister mit der
Innenministerin um herauszufinden warum
Leute aus Moldau nicht nach Norwegen
wollen und habe herausgefunden weil
niemand erfahren hat wo man sich dafür
anmelden kann das wurde einer
internationalen Organisation übertragen
das würde so schlecht umgesetzt wir
schreiben nämlich seinen Bericht dazu
das war einfach dilettantisch und dann
kam niemand nach Norwegen aber es sind
jeden Tag 1000 Menschen mit den Bussen
aus Moldau über Rumänien nach Österreich
und Deutschland gefahren weil das
wussten sie diese Länder kannten sie da
haben Sie davon gehört ich glaube man
müsste jetzt vielleicht weg von der
Parteipolitik irgendwo einmal ein Essen
haben für zwei Tage und sich überlegen
wenn eine spanische NGO vor wenigen
Wochen sagt wir fürchten dass die Hälfte
der Ukraine die jetzt in Spanien sind in
andere Länder gehen werden weil sie hier
nicht genug Unterstützung bekommen und
in Spanien sind aber nur sehr wenige
kann man darüber einen europäischen
Dialog haben kann man eine europäischen
Fonds einrichten wir reden von der
größten flüchtlingskatastrophe seit den
40er Jahren das wird auch Geld kosten
wir müssen auch in der Ukraine den
Binnenvertriebenen mehr helfen sie nicht
alle zu uns kommen
ich würde gerne noch mal weil sie sagen
es ist die größte Katastrophe seit den
40ern Frau wird man macht sich Sorgen um
die gesellschaftliche Stimmung um die
Gesellschaft um den gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt viele sagen wir müssen
aufpassen dass wir dass wir unsere
Gesellschaft nicht überfordern mit so
vielen Flüchtlingen wie beobachten Sie
das wir sehen ein Anwachsen der AFD wir
sehen ganz klar eine große Demo hier am
Samstag wo es heißt Deutschland zuerst
wie beobachten Sie das und wie schafft
man das eine Gesellschaft da
zusammenzuhalten das ist die eine
Million Euro Frage ganz bestimmt wir
merken natürlich dass die Anspannung
größer wird wir merken bei unseren
ehrenamtlichen auch dass sie langsam an
ihre
Kapazitätsgrenze kommen weil das sie
natürlich total frustriert die Menschen
nicht mehr so unterstützen zu können wie
sie es eigentlich die ganze Zeit gemacht
haben und von daher
wir sehen aber trotzdem nicht dass die
Stimmung kippt es ist nach wie vor eine
große Solidarität da und es ist der
Zusammenhalt ist schon noch da und wir
sollten meiner Meinung nach das
Auseinanderbrechen unserer Gesellschaft
auch nicht zu hochreden weil damit geben
wir nämlich genau den rechten Positionen
immer wieder aufs Neue Vorschub und und
Unterstützung und deshalb denke ich wir
sollten viel mehr daran
appellieren dass wir weiter solidarisch
bleiben dass wir uns sehr nach wie vor
oder weiterhin so unterstützen wie wir
es in der Vergangenheit gemacht haben
und ich möchte mich an der Stelle
einfach für alle die im Rahmen der
flüchtlingskrisen die wir ja nun lange
genug haben bei allen Ehrenamtlichen
bedanken weil ohne die Ehrenamtlichen
hätten diese Krisen so sehr Krisen
werden können wie wir es niemals erlebt
hätten und von daher herzlichen Dank an
alle unsere ehrenamtliche ist das ein
Punkt vor Puder wo man sagt man muss
einfach noch mal mehr versuchen wirklich
an Solidarität zu appellieren wir sind
noch immer reiches Land auch wenn wir
jetzt große Krisen haben dass man sagt
auf diese Art kann man das bewältigen
also ich möchte auf ausdrücklich
zustimmen genau die Solidarität ist da
die Solidarität ist hoch und diese
Solidarität bleibt hoch wenn man das
System unbürokratisch regelt wie wir es
bisher gemacht haben weil viele
Ehrenamtliche sind ganz oft an dieser
Bürokratie gescheitert und wir haben uns
ja vorgenommen auch als Koalition
möglichst schnell die Integration zu
ermöglichen sowohl von ukrainischen
geflüchteten in den Arbeitsmarkt als
auch für die übrigen geflüchteten
Arbeitsverbote abzuschaffen die es nach
wie vor noch gibt so dass wir dann am
möglichst viele Menschen haben die sehr
schnell hier ankommen können und auch
selbstbestimmt zu leben und dann
vielleicht auch schnell Arbeit finden
das ist eine sehr wichtige Aufgabe damit
die Solidarität bleibt okay dann sie
noch die letzten 20 Sekunden sind
unglaublich wichtig eine riesengroße
Hilfe ohne die es nicht geht und was wir
brauchen ist eine Asylpolitik mit Herz
und Verstand und Regelungen und das
braucht es und das entlastet dann auch
die Ehrenamtlichen und motiviert sie vor
allen Dingen auch okay dann sind wir ist
unsere Arbeit das ist relativ ich denke
das dauert noch ein bisschen bis sie
sich da völlig einig sind vielen Dank
Frau Lindholz obwohl dann vielen Dank
Herr Knauß fürs mit diskutieren vielen
dank ihnen fürs zuschauen morgen ist
mein Kollege Alexander Kähler hier und
der diskutiert über die Frage Inflation
Energiekrise was hält unsere Wirtschaft
eigentlich aus bis dann tschüss
[Musik]